[music]
hello, i'm ursula von der leyen and
i would be president of
the european commission for the next five years,
one europe that's 500 million
people in 28 countries with 24
different languages ​​i have
a top team with my commission from all
regions of europe and we  want to
use all our strength for europe and for
its people
these people want a strong
economy that creates jobs and sustainable
prosperity they want europe
to become a climate-neutral continent
and to be successful in the digital age
they expect protection for the weak
and security for everyone
they want  investments in education and
research and innovation
because that creates the opportunities for
tomorrow for us europeans,
the rule of law and democracy are paramount
and you want a self-confident
europe that is a good neighbor and a
good partner
we feel committed to these goals
let’s get to work
go